feedbacks have won three games in a row
and seven of their last eight they can
take both these games for san diego at
the end of this quick two-game visit
here to chase field your ram truck
starter for the diamondbacks riley smith
the right-hander activated today from
the alt site after an injury yesterday
the scheduled starter taylor widener
fernando tatis will step in laid things
off here blind to short and a nice scoop
there by ahmed and he fires the first
for the out one away i wonder what that
was off the bat 7.1 miles an hour my
goodness it was crushed and that was
like just a stab by ahmed out there
start against la last time outstanding
yeah and the confidence resonates with
me and you look at ryan weather's
numbers five games
definitely the two starts and those were
against the los angeles dodgers and a
minuscule era the ball inside two-and-oh
here on carson kelly and out comes
jace tingler and he's looking for the
trainer i think they think something is
wrong here with weather's
two pitches into this ball game he
throws much harder than 88 perhaps some
concern when they saw the reading on
that radar guy
keep a close eye on their young lefty
out there a long conversation in between
innings says it looks to me like
weathers is done for the night as feet
through a total of 19 pitches in that
inning and now you get nick ramirez up
in the pen there is a switch hitter
jericho profile he'll bat left-handed
[Applause]
quickly two down in the second
double play and a nice turn there by
wyatt matheson to complete that double
play to ahmed and then back to matheson
three six three and nick's been
scuffling he's only got seven hits and
fifty at bats and they'll go after him
here in the second inning with the
runner at second now two down that's
trying to stay fair down the line and
it's off the wall there comes eduardo
nick comment and hit second with an rbi
double and it's one nothing diamondbacks
yeah we're just saying that that's
nobody out in left field they were
playing straight up which means they
almost draw a line from first base bag
to second base bag and straight out the
left field and that opens up all the
left field side and that's exactly where
ah man hit that ball and boy that was
gonna be an easy double it'd be whether
it was gonna be a triple
so two quick outs for nick ramirez here
in the third inning david smith coming
up and that changeup is popped up left
side long run for manny only guy there
he gets there to make a running catch in
fair territory covered an awful lot of
ground to make that play but he did it
and that's it for arizona in the third a
one two three inning for nick ramirez a
couple of quick outs for the sidewinding
right-hander wyatt matheson coming up
ryan matheson hits one deep to left phil
then it's gone
wyatt mathison's first of the year and
it's two nothing
that was a cannon shot
106.7 miles an hour off the back
ball sizzled out of here oh my god
right there middle of the zone tailing
back to the barrel of the bat and wyatt
did not miss it
carson kelly was saying it's a young
team they're gonna rely on each other
help each other out the super subs and
it again
and back to back singles it put runners
on the quarters and nobody out here at
the top of the fifth awesome kim coming
to the plate runner goes from first to
the pitches lined into right center
field that'll be a base hit profar's
going to score carratini is on his way
to third base he will be waived caratini
coming home and there will be no throw
to the plate kim ends up at second of
the game is tied 2-2 here in the fifth
victor caratini scoring from first
josh rojas
kicked this ball in the outfield
a line drive missile from hanson kim
after working the count back to 3-2
caratini running on the play gets it
this ball is booted by josh rojas which
allows carrottini to come all the way
around from first to score and this is a
tie ball game
runners on the corners nobody out game
tied in two at the top of the fifth
national league player of the week is at
the plate on the ground and through into
left field a base hit kim will score
from third and the padres take a 3-2
lead
they are in front for the first time
tonight well the padres
certainly swing in the bat with runners
in scoring positioning through these
first five
fernando gets a change up it's elevated
with the infield kind of in playing in
that middle area
not too not too deep not too far in he
still gets it by for an rbi single so
the bases loaded nobody out manny hit
the plate andre's leading three to two
in the fifth this ball is hit well to
left field peralta on the run dives
can't get it and it gets behind him that
may empty the bases musgrove has scored
fernando has scored trent grisham is on
his way home he will score manny to
third and a three-run triple
padres have busted it wide open here in
the fifth inning six to two san diego
ah the padres are feeling it now
love the approach by manny machado this
is set up from his first at-bat he took
that fastball away
this is a breaking ball
off the end of the bat but perfect
placement
peralta was diving after this one
and heads up
wind them up bobby dickerson
big inning for the padres that's quite
the gamble
laying it out jake creditworth will hit
for austin adams one out base is empty
left-handed hitter this is in the air to
right field that is back and it is gone
a home run jake cronenworth homers and
the padres take a 7-2 lead the offense
is awake in the desert of arizona
tonight who needs a stinking mental day
apparently not jay cronin worth he's all
smiles coming around
third
this is going to turn out to be a fine
day for him
won it back
one swing
one home run his second of the season
the other one of course that bomb
against power on the hanging curve ball
a couple of sundays ago nick has got a
double rbi tonight he'll have runners at
first and third and a
base hit center field
run scores 7-3
stopping at second peralta kavero scores
tommy's got a second
[Applause]
[Music]
going down going away and nick just one
handed this ball into center field
so two on and nobody out for ha sung kim
at an rbi single in the fifth king gets
a fastball here grounds it fair down the
third base line headed towards the left
field corner bro far has scored
caratini's on his way to third he'll
stop there rbi double ha sung kim ball
gets away momentarily on the infield but
that won't matter and now an eight to
three padre lead in the eighth and still
nobody out so now meyer is wearing one
of those branded face masks on the
ground and under the glove of ahmed
coming in from third base is carratini
and the padres make it 9-3
will myers with a pinch hit rbi single
and the padres lead it by six
and now nine to three padres in the
eighth and now fernando tatis junior
swinging a drive hit to pretty deep
right center
back is rojas at the fence he leaps
[Applause]
he took a home run away from tatis kim
is home it's another run but what a play
by josh rojas
oh that looked like it had three run
home run written all over a nice play by
rojas lead off man aboard here in the
ninth inning and jorge mateo coming up
first pitch swinging matteo skies one
deep to left field this one is gonna go
his first major league home run
and the padres add-on again here in the
nine 12-3 san diego
well you know what you've been saying it
all night how good it is for guys like
matteo and kim to get the opportunity to
get some at bats here and boy have they
taken advantage this is why you use your
bench
and now the big right-hander into his
delivery the pitch to rojas is on the
outside corner and strike three call
that's all for this one
mark malanson comes on in a non-save
situation to get the final three outs
the padre offense comes alive in a big
way